who is Frank Miller and what makes him
such a big deal his many works have
redefined classic characters and
revitalized the comics industry Frank
Miller grew up in Vermont pouring
himself into comics kung fu movies and
crime fiction as a youth upon moving to
New York City in 1977 Miller worked as a
carpenter to pay rent he frequently hung
out in the lobbies of DC and Marvel
pestering editors and artists for advice
on his work he came across famous artist
Neal Adams who gave Miller lessons on
drawing comic book art Adams helped
Miller get his first work on the comic
book series of The Twilight Zone which
led to a few other stints as a cover
artist at Marvel this led to penciling
jobs on spider-man in the late 70s and
Miller pitched some ideas to revamp the
character daredevil a very unpopular
character with low sales at the time
Frank Miller was only 22 years old when
he debuted on daredevil issue 158 in
1979 Miller's work on daredevil received
high critical acclaim and helped the
failing title sell big numbers on the
comic-book stands during his run in the
1980s he eventually would take over
writing duties as well and created the
beloved character the sexiest ass and
Elektra Frank Miller's shadowy crime
fighter's and daredevil influenced one
of the biggest pop culture phenomenon of
all time the Ninja Turtles
for example the sensei splinter is a
parody of stick Daredevils mentor the
Foot Clan is a parody of the hand the
evil ninja clan that daredevil fights
Raphael carries a pair of Sai weapons
like Elektra and in the first issue the
origin story of the turtles mirrors the
same origin story of daredevil daredevil
went on to become a movie in 2003
starring Ben Affleck with a spin-off
about Elektra starring Jennifer Garner
in 2005 those movies were panned by
critics and fans but daredevil will be
getting a reboot for an upcoming Netflix
original TV series with Marvel Studios
starring Charlie Cox in 2015
in 1983 Frank Miller wrote and drew
Ronan a graphic novel about a ronin
samurai who is reincarnated in a
futuristic New York Ronin was a
breakthrough for comics it was printed
on high-quality heavy stock paper and
was controlled by a single creator
uninhibited by corporate restraints this
was very rare in American comics at the
time Ronan's popularity went on to
inspire the Cartoon Network show Samurai
Jack and the sci-fi channel is
developing a ronin miniseries for TV for
2015 in 1986 the comics industry
exploded with Frank Miller's Batman The
Dark Knight Returns inspired by a
midlife crisis and Dirty Harry movies
ranked Miller wrote an epic
tale of an aged Batman returning to
fight the evils of a corrupt Gotham this
book shoved away the kam penis of Batman
the book went on to sell over a million
copies after that Hillier moved to Los
Angeles to work in the film business
Miller worked on the screenplay for
Robocop 2 and found the experience
frustrating because he did not have as
much creative control as he wanted
quickly he decided to quit Hollywood in
the 90s Miller returned to comics
working for Dark Horse publishing
graphic novels like Sin City hard-boiled
and big guy and rusty the boy robot
which later became a Saturday morning
cartoon show before being adapted into a
movie Sin City was very influential on
filmmakers such as Darren Aronofsky
Darren Aronofsky said in an interview
with indieWIRE that his breakthrough
film pie was inspired visually by the
Sin City comics as Hollywood reached the
new millennium Frank Miller's work would
see mainstream success like never before
the Christopher Nolan Batman trilogy
took many ideas from Frank Miller's
Batman year one and The Dark Knight
Returns
for example replacing the sleek
Batmobile with the military-grade
tumbler Batman escaping police with a
bat homing device The Dark Knight Rises
involves an older Batman with a cane
who's been retired from crime-fighting
Bruce Wayne modifies his old limbs with
a mechanical exoskeleton in 2005 as
comic book movies became increasingly
important to Hollywood Miller was
brought on to co-direct the movie Sin
City with Robert Rodriguez the 2014
sequel a dame to kill for was
co-directed again by Frank Miller and
Robert Rodriguez his graphic novel 300
was adapted by Zack Snyder for Warner
Brothers and met huge box-office success
grossing half a billion dollars
worldwide 300 success led to a sequel
300 rise of an empire in 2014 and earned
over 300 million dollars in the box
office in 2008 Frank Miller wrote and
directed the spirit an adaptation of
will eisenerz 1940s newspaper comic
which fell flat to critics and audiences
felt it was too much of a Sin City rip
off and not faithful enough to the
original material but in 2013 came Hugh
Jackman's The Wolverine
directed by James Mangold and largely
influenced by the work of Frank Miller
and Chris Claremont 1982 miniseries
Wolverine the story is set in Japan
focusing as usual on Frank Miller's love
for ninjas martial arts and samurai
culture also in 2013 Zack Snyder
announced at the San Diego Comic Con
that Batman vs Superman will be inspired
by Miller's The Dark Knight Returns and
quoted excerpts from the book at the
presentation after the
Smit sales for the book surged 100 61%
breaking records for DC Comics Frank
Miller is a big deal because his works
have influenced many large properties in
pop culture film television and
literature his ideas and movies have
grossed huge numbers in the box office
and his stories have impacted audiences
all around the world what's your
favorite Frank Miller comic what's your
favorite Frank Miller movie
what other comic book visionaries would
you like us to make videos about let us
know in the comments below
[Music]
[Music]
you